welcome to philanthropy in action where
we engage philanthropist activists
students and the community in
discussions on how we use our time
talent and treasure to change the world
I am maxim thorn and I teach
philanthropy in action at Yale
University
today's guest is Liesel Pritzker Simmons
who has committed herself to innovative
philanthropy thank you for being here
Liesl Liesl is doing very important work
in Ghana and her life reflects a very
involved life with philanthropy we also
have our Yale University students who
are joining our conversation
welcome to the show please introduce
yourselves Linda I am a junior history
major and I come from Shanghai China my
name is Dan Tirzah I'm from Chicago
Illinois studying psychology my name is
Leslie ball I'm studying international
development and I'm from Washington DC
hi my name is McClain Roselle I'm from
Denmark spur Colorado and I'm studying
art history hi I'm Stephen Banks I'm
from Detroit Michigan and I'm studying
computer science my name is Michael
Schulten I'm the senior from Chattanooga
Tennessee and I'm studying religion
thank you Lisa
I'm so glad you're here because you have
a life that so many of us would longed
to have you have been accomplished in
many different fields how did you make
the choices you've made to use your time
your talent and treasure to do the
things that you're not doing to make the
world a better place well I think that
it really kind of isn't a choice I think
if if you are a committed member of
society and you understand the influence
that you can have and you feel
responsible to you know fight and
justices or to to really try to fight
for equality then you don't really have
a choice but to engage and I guess
I feel that I was so lucky to be born in
this position where you know I have food
to eat I have clean water to drink I
have a community of people that support
me and so why not use that amazing base
to try to make more people in that
position as well as I'd like to talk
about that a little bit
we've had other conversations with
people who did not come to embracing the
particular position that they're in
where they could be a wealth holder
where they have a platform in media
where they didn't have any of the tools
that you have that you you're
comfortable and embracing what was it in
your background do you think that
allowed you to take on these challenges
so young well it was tricky I mean it
wasn't it was kind of a conscious choice
because you know not to kind of like
dwell on this too much but it's a little
weird when you realize at an early age
that you have a lot of wealth and that
people are associating you with that and
so and I see a lot of peer group people
in my peer group struggle with that and
they don't kind of it's it's almost like
the secret that they want to hide and I
just think that's unproductive I
understand it but it's not productive
and so why not kind of embrace that and
say okay well what what can I do with
this situation instead of running away
from it but I think that that's that's
actually it's it's not an easy choice
necessarily because you always want to
be identifying with I don't know
opportunities that you don't have as
opposed to taking advantage of the ones
that you do and I think also for young
people sometimes to say I'm a full-time
philanthropist so I'm a philanthropist
makes you almost you don't want to be
considered a socialite right and so
that's that's also I think a little bit
tricky and
so if you don't want to be considered a
socialite then don't do social lytic
philanthropy like do it the way you want
to do it I think I think that's such a
that's such a great framing of of that
question because when we as the class
began talking about this people are
comfortable talking about their home
life their religion their intimate
relations their boyfriends or
girlfriends but very uncomfortable of
talking about money mm-hmm and I often
wonder how we can overcome that barrier
because I think if we got people to come
to Owen at the position and the
opportunities that those positions give
them then we could actually begin to
engage more fully in creating change
yeah I think that I also think though
that that perhaps because there's so
much information available to people
today that that's gonna be less and less
of an issue so the thing is you can
google me and find my net worth
somewhere out there and and I know that
and so the thing is is it makes its I've
less incentive to run away from that
because people are gonna find it out
anyway right you know so why not why not
then take control of what you're doing
with that information so directing
people towards okay no it's not just
that look here's you know a young rich
girl but these are some interesting
issues that that money is addressing and
so you can actually use that to call
attention to issue areas that you're
passionate about Linda I know that you
are passionate about a number of things
please I am a huge fan of the little
princess I cried and cried for most of
the movie but it's great to see that the
little princess is going to be a
successful women in the fields of
philanthropy and I would like to focus
on that in terms of how do you invest
your treasure so you are a talented
actress and your hobby is theater I was
wondering how do these interests
translate into your work in philanthropy
and how have the skill sets you
developed in these sectors helped you in
the philanthropic sector that is an
excellent question I think
because I've thought about that a lot
because I've stopped acting
professionally now but there's a lot
that I've learned from my training as an
actor that really does translate so one
one of the best lessons that that I was
taught in terms of acting is whenever
you approach a scene and whenever you
approach you know your relationship with
the other character always ask yourself
how do you want to make the other person
feel that directs your intention and
your objective for that scene so what
how are you trying to make that person
feel right that in there and the thing
is I think that that's actually a better
life question so when you walk into any
situation and when you see someone
whether or not they look like you or
whether or not they're from the same
place or whether they have you know two
legs or are living in a refugee camp how
do you want to make them feel and where
I think philanthropy then takes it a
step further and development takes it a
step further from theater is how not
only how do you want to make them feel
in this scene but what about them in ten
years what about them in 20 years and so
development is also about answering that
question as well but I think that that
that kind of and I don't want to say
empathy because it's a little bit
different than empathy but that thought
process absolutely informs my
philanthropy that's great now I am also
a big fan of a little princess and I
just bright you know I was looking
through your files like you said you can
google your name and it's that
relatively easy to find some some great
information that's really phenomenal at
what you've done it's such a young age
and I you know I was actually I was
really interested in you know in your
philanthropic efforts and I also found a
little bit of information on young young
ambassadors for opportunity and I
thought that was a really great program
and there was a lot of information
online but I did want to ask you a
little bit more about
that because I think in this day and age
it seems you know what this this
overpopulated planet and and it almost
is a little bit more I find it more it's
more challenging to to become a leader
in your community or and I think with
you know with the the new digital media
age there there's more opportunities for
that but I think it's it's almost
difficult to make a name for yourself
and and and lead your community and I
was just really interested in how you've
expanded that program and and what you
advise for us and how you know how we
can be leaders in our own communities
yeah I think so the young ambassadors
for opportunity actually started while I
was in college and I became involved
with an organization called opportunity
International which is a microfinance
Network and they're awesome they do
really fantastic work very innovative
stuff and we've actually our foundation
is partnered with them on a program that
we have in Ghana but I went to a
conference an opportunity international
conference as a potential donor and it
liked everything I was seeing and then I
learned a lot more in depth about their
microfinance programs and then I went
back to college and was telling all my
friends about it and they were like wow
this sounds really cool like how do we
get involved and I was like well there's
no way like there's they're not they're
not really interested in like the mass
market donor or donor engagement in from
the American end they're really
interested in getting like a million
dollar check from Gates Foundation or
from USAID or from like a whale donor as
they say and I went to opportunity
international I said well that doesn't
make any sense look my friends maybe
they can't write most of them can't
write a cheque like I can write but you
should tell them about what you're doing
these are future senators these are
future leaders of businesses these are
future they should know what economic
development is at the grassroots level
in countries that are developing rapidly
and you're you have an opportunity to do
that so we started the young ambassadors
for opportunity
it's kind of an Education Network about
you know how microfinance works there
was and it was right around the time
when when Muhammad Yunus won the Nobel
Peace Prize and so there was there was a
lot of conversation about microfinance
and also a lot of misconceptions that it
was sort of like the silver bullet which
isn't true it's one of many tools that
are necessary for economic development
so anyway we started the young
ambassadors and we started with a
National Board and then what we did was
was really decentralized it so each city
kind of has their own chapter and they
can set their own agenda but with some
oversight from the National Board and
then within the organization we set it
up that way because we wanted to create
opportunities for leaders in each of
those places because we recognized that
our you know constituency which is
mostly you know 20-somethings wanted
those leadership opportunities and so
instead of just having one national
board and a ton of members we really
have a lot of leaders at the local level
that can set their own agenda
so I think that that's creating
leadership opportunities within
organizations gives people something it
helps engagement so I would that's
that's how we structured that one and
and it's it's been good also because
then over the last few years I've kind
of stepped down from like I'm cycling
off the board this year because now it's
formed and it's it's time for someone
else to take it over and bring some
fresh ideas to it this will tell us
about the structure of your foundation
and some of the interesting dynamics
because in your foundation you share
leadership with your mother how does
that work I have any of you worked with
your parents before because
it's it's it's rewarding and challenging
like at the same time so what we did was
in 2008 I decided a few years earlier I
kind of took control of my wealth and I
decided to take 50 million dollars and
set up a foundation and at that time I
didn't really feel like I had the skill
set to lead that and kind of manage that
and it's something I mean my mom is very
is a passionate philanthropist as well
so she is technically the president of
the foundation and I'm the vice
president and but we really work
together on setting the vision and the
mission and the strategy for the
foundation but what I kind of like about
that is that I myself from getting some
leadership development training you know
because I I've never run a foundation
before and so at least working at I
think it's also important not only to be
a leader but create development
opportunities for you as well because
you you know you should always
constantly be learning so when we set it
up that way
you know the goal is and you know ten
years or so or whatever less than that
whenever my mom decides to step down
that I will then run the foundation but
I've liked actually being in that number
two position for these early years
because I'm learning a lot Dan so some
of the organizations that I think you've
worked with have been using microfinance
to fund low cost schools I'm in Ghana
can you tell us a little bit more about
that and if you think that there are
other kinds of institutions that
microfinance could partner with
synergistically that way in the future
that's a great question I
so our program that we are working on in
Ghana is basically using microfinance
and microfinance products to improve
schools and so we work with this kind of
little-known sector of these low-cost
private schools that actually focus on
deprived communities
where there either is no government
school or the government school is too
far away or it's overcrowded you know
members of the community just sort of
set up their own school and they charge
a you know an affordable tuition to the
parents these are basically
not-for-profit schools and so there are
some for-profit schools but we focus on
not-for-profit schools and then you know
they use that tuition to pay the
teachers and run the school but
technically they're a business and so
like any business they might need a loan
to grow because even though there's
schools they don't get any government
support because they're technically
private so what we part we partnered
with an MFI and Ghana to try to create a
program that would make it easier to
lend to these schools because
microfinance institutions tend not to
like to lend to schools they're tricky
loan clients they don't fit well in a
group lending model all of these reasons
and so we developed and then tested
these different loan products and so
there are things like a lot of
proprietors want a loan to buy a school
bus so that they can transport the
children they can get further out and
get kids in more rural areas so it
increases their enrollment and then they
can also rent that bust out during the
school day so it's an income generating
activity for the school as well and so
and what we liked about using
microfinance is when you go into these
regions you know extremely rural areas
and sub-saharan Africa you can get
microfinance can go there a lot of other
interventions can't really go very deep
and very far but when you have a loan
officer looking over their loan
portfolio and their school is in that
loan portfolio they're gonna go and
monitor that school they're gonna tell
you if teachers aren't showing up
they're going to tell you if because if
the school can't repay the loan it's on
their back so that that basically that
feedback mechanism of microfinance
is very well managed much better managed
than the government circulating amongst
the schools and so we thought well let's
let's use that delivery method to bring
some better education into the schools
as well but we have didn't did you find
that people were surprised that there
are private schools for lower-income
folks operating in Africa as a model
it's been such an uphill battle to
explain this sector to people because as
soon as you say the word private school
particularly to somebody from from the
West
immediately they don't want to hear
about it they're like nope school and
and the other thing is is that the big
debate is should educate like is free
education - right and we can sure okay
it's a right that it's who's gonna pay
for that actually somebody's going to
pay for it it's either our tax dollars
you know or coming so what's the the
better question is not should education
be free but what is the most cost
efficient form of education and there
have been studies that show that these
low cost private schools are cheaper per
student for the same quality of
education as the government-run student
M schools and so if that's true then
let's use that delivery method you know
or some or some hybrid partnership of a
public private education model the
interesting thing that I find especially
if Americans are surprised by private
education in Africa or in these
developing countries forming this
transformative space or opportunity as
surprising is surprising to me so one of
the ears of my research is how American
philanthropy transform this space for
African Americans through from the
slavery period the antebellum South
reconstruction
post Jim during Jim Crow post Jim Crow
and that we've actually seen in the
United States how philanthropist through
private institutions because public
opportunities weren't there for a lot of
african-americans and people of color or
if they were there they weren't opened
to to African Americans and so Spelman
and Morehouse and any number or the
Rosenwald family that created the vast
scale for a freaking Americans why do
you think there is that gap in knowledge
of what we know we've done but it's so
different when you're applying to a
continent like Africa why do you think
there's that dissonance you mean between
specifically with private school yes or
since that's one of your focus areas I
think one problem is is just the the
what the paradigm has been around
international development it's for sixty
years you know the the development
agencies have been saying no you know
let's strengthen and build capacity
within the government's make these
governments really big and strong and
powerful so that then they can deliver
these services to the people and there
hasn't been as much of a focus I think
on on these development agencies and the
private sector so the two there's kind
of siloed I find do you think that's a
generational thing do you find that
debate between yourself and your mother
for example and reflected in that well
she's very much a private sector you
know she's sort of almost
anti-government but yeah I mean I think
that that's certainly of topical debate
I mean this year how big should
government be you know what services
should it provide and what's what
services is it capable of providing as
well and it's it's interesting but I do
find even in my own politics sometimes a
divorce between what I'm what I would be
recommending to the Minister of
Education in Ghana and then what I
expect of her
American system here right so yeah I
think it's just years and years and
years of its
expecting that government should provide
everything and now people are saying
maybe not actually maybe there are
better actors in certain areas Stephen
so you mentioned that you entered
philanthropy because you felt a
responsibility how would you recommend
engaging potential donors who don't feel
that responsibility that's a tough one
I think that that some people really
feel that you know it's either not there
it's not their responsibility or also
something that I hear a lot is well no
no no I need to make my money now and
then I'll I'll give it away once I once
once we take the tech company public you
know and I guess I think may be a good
way to engage those kind of reluctant
potential donors is storytelling you
know if you can if you can engage them
with an individual that whose life could
be changed because they did decide to
feel responsible or they did decide to
be empathetic I think I've found that to
be the most effective appeal bringing it
to a one-on-one level sometimes people
get really overwhelmed by big statistics
and you know when they say well great so
my you know my $5,000 it's gonna be a
drop in the bucket I'm not gonna solve
sex trafficking but you know bring it
down to almost like the starfish
metaphor right was like well you saved
that one starfish so so do you think it
really is the moral responsibility that
they're ignoring or are they correct in
saying that they can choose to not have
that responsibility or to not feel that
responsibility I believe it is there
there I think it's a moral imperative
personally because
you know we are we are a community of
people we need to help each other you
don't you know you're alone on an island
you will die and so I think that it's
just completely against every human
instinct to deny helping somebody else I
mean what do you think that it's it's
it's an it's a moral responsibility or
do you think it's a choice
no I don't know I I study moral
philosophy a bit and there's this
question of whether there is an
objective morality or not and I don't
have the answer to that yet I doubt that
I will but it it's a good question
did you so you got married to the
handsome and sophisticated Ian Simmons
did you have these conversations with
him yeah something that we did we
actually did this right after we got
married was we created a family mission
statement and kind of sat down it was
actually lovely like we got the fire
going
and it's like sat there and it was great
like cold through the library we had
John Rawls out we had a Martius then we
did we could totally dork tout and
really thought about okay well what is
so so so what is it that we feel as a
family so now we're we're a unit we're
married and what is it how do we want to
conduct ourselves how do we want to
interact with the world and so we made
this mission statement and then you know
based on this how do we want to invest
our money based on this how do we want
to give our dollars and give up our time
and so yeah that is absolutely it's a
very active conversation I think and it
helps with framing your philanthropy you
know so that it's not just like oh I'll
give everything to everybody you know
like you kind of then can focus it and
you can say well no these are the things
that I really do believe that I can have
an impact at and these are the reasons
that I feel that way so I think that
kind of dial
so healthy to have and always be
changing it to questioning it that's it
the sexually ties perfectly into what I
wanted to ask you so since you think
that the wealthy or maybe everyone has a
moral obligation to give back to society
one of the debates that came up in our
class is whether society can just
encourage the wealthy to give their
money back or whether it would be
morally okay to have something like the
government forcing the wealthy to give
back say after they die what are your
thoughts on that I think that I I would
tend to keep I would tend to keep the
government out of it because by
definition then it will get political
right so and I think the politics of
giving is a bit rocky and something I
struggle with personally so I think that
I mean I'm absolutely in favor of
raising taxes on the wealthy and in that
way contributing to government resources
and civil society development but I
think that forcing like like a
philanthropy tax or something like that
on some of these death I'm not sure that
that would be an effective use of those
dollars because would that person then
like would the person be allowed to say
where it goes to or they would just have
to give you know 5% or something to any
charitable cause I mean you can set it
up either way we talked about both
scenarios in class and whether one would
be more acceptable than the other or
whether or not acceptable what do you
think I'm not a huge fan of the idea in
part because I think it would be great
if everybody just everyone was giving
but I don't think you can legislate
people into being a good people yeah
yeah yeah I think I think that's a good
I think that's a good point
it's yeah forcing somebody to have a
belief that you want them to have is not
American
Michael um so kind of combining this
philosophical term that we seem to have
taken with the practical work that you
do how did you decide to look abroad as
one focus of your of your philanthropy
versus things closer to home you know I
get asked that a lot and it's a good
question because honestly I can tell you
much more about the education system in
Ghana than I can about New York City
public schools which is where I live and
the reason really is kind of by
circumstance so one thing that we I was
actually volunteering in Tanzania and I
met my mother in Ghana because we'd
heard that opportunity International was
just kind of beginning to lend to
schools they weren't sure how to do it
or you know kind of what the problem was
we were just forming the foundation and
so we met up in Ghana and started just
kind of asking lots of questions and saw
this opportunity that there was a gap
here in this market that microfinance
institutions couldn't figure out how to
lend to schools and schools couldn't
figure out how to manage themselves well
enough to get these loans so there was a
there was an opportunity there to create
a program and that's that's really why
we ended up there so it wasn't something
where we said here's this idea where
should we go we found it in the
communities that we ended up working in
and now we're looking at replicating
that program in other places is your
value added as you see it that you are
able to one take greater risks and to
find these gaps so you are in a sense
not investing in what other what is
actually already happening wherever it's
happening but that you're seeking out
spaces that you can have an impact and
leave a mark are those two things
operating at the same time yeah
I think that and it's interesting this
is always a debate that I have with
myself of you know wanting to be a
leader and leave a mark
but then also something that I think
that people don't do enough of us be a
good joiner like there should be awards
for best middle management you know and
and and I think a lot of areas suffer
from too many people and you touched on
this a little bit before too many people
starting things instead of kind of
trying to join or strengthen the whole
community and so so we do with the
foundation both so we like this program
we've developed but with partners so
we're not we're not going to start a
microfinance institution that do this
will partner with one that already does
and then there are some grants that we
make that are honestly writing a check
to a great organization so that they can
continue to do their work and you know
we say send us your report and we'll see
you in a year you know so I think I
think it's important to do both you know
to develop develop a program
particularly in issue areas that you
really care about so efficient models
for education and then if it's something
that's wonderful like you know
Parkinson's disease research I cannot
add to that field at all except with
treasure and so yeah you just look at it
guys but I was curious
a couple questions first are you
considering raising a family in the
coming years okay and you know we
earlier on this semester we studied
warren buffett and and you know that the
the dynasty of the buffets and i really
wanted to ask you if you know with with
your with your treasurer and with your
experience and and and with your
inheritance as well were you I mean what
would you do for we because with when
the buffets they he
isn't that people not he will not be
having his children inherit very much
money and and so I was curious what
would you do for your figure children
would you would you want them to create
a life of their own and and build their
dynasty or would and and donate most of
your treasure to philanthropic
philanthropic means or would you want to
pass on a large you know a large chunk
of your of your treasure to your
children to builds a foundation or what
would kind of voice your goal that's and
we totally we're like right I'm sure
even smiling over there we're completely
like having these conversations and I
think that the first and most important
thing and this is one thing that I love
with working with my mom is the the best
thing that kids can inherit is sort of
the moral compass kind of that your
parents give you and your sense your
worldview kind of obviously it's your
own worldview but it's very much shaped
by what your parents tell you and teach
you and so you know that I think is what
we want to emphasize in our family is
that create a culture of inquiry
create a culture of responsibility but
not of pressure around those things
because I don't think you know like if
my children don't grow up to be
philanthropist that's perfectly fine and
they should grow up to be whoever they
want to be and so I'm not sure that it's
a good idea to embed in a financial plan
kind of almost like you shall you shall
run a foundation and it shall be
involved in strategic philanthropy and
like you know what I mean so I think
that it's an ongoing dialogue but the
first thing I think that we plan on
doing is involving our kids in our
giving so what are the things you know
what are the things that they care about
how can they see that engaging in these
causes can make a difference I think
that's important do you think
what that being a woman in this space
you know throughout the field of
philanthropy we hear of you know mr.
Carnegie and mr. Rockefeller and mr.
gates and mr. Buffett has that played a
role in how you approach these questions
you know it's interesting I almost feel
like a little bit opposite on that like
there's something sort of soft touch
about the philanthropy space you know
like something's sort of feminine about
charity and giving and in a way that is
funny because the founders of all of
these foundations were men but I've
often felt a little bit of a pressure to
like butch up my conversation with like
metrics and you know we've got to be
very measurable around it instead of
talking about you know you know
children's faces and things like that
and so I've almost felt a little that is
that there's something quite feminine
about philanthropy in a funny way
because as you as you point out most of
the contributors financially doesn't
space have been men I don't know it
might that might just be the marketing
around it you know that we're moving
from you know Sally Struthers you know
with with children in the street to you
know Muhammad Yunus and economics you
know well I think you're a wonderful
addition to this space and couldn't
thank you enough for sharing your
insights how you approach a philanthropy
how you've engaged with Ian and your mom
all the things that we are grappling
with in this class the class by the way
is in a few weeks giving away $100,000
that's so cool and they are empowered to
make those decisions and so it's
wonderful to have your perspective which
is so highly relevant to what they're
doing this has been a wonderful
conversation with Lisa Pritzker she
shared so much with us and inspired me
and I can see from the faces of our
students inspired the students as well
she's passionately talked about
the challenge between the cold economic
metrics and the smile it makes me wonder
what are you doing to make the world a
better place